hi I'm John castle at Wolfram research
I'm gonna be talking about representing
biological sequences in the Wolfram
language we're gonna show you how to
bring in DNA RNA amino acid protein to
protein sequences and do all kinds of
great processes on them all your typical
translation transcription although all
those kinds of things finding features
inside of biological sequences such as
genes and mutations and all together
you're gonna see that a Wolfram is
making great strides for processing
genetic data hi everybody thanks for
coming I'm John Castle I'll be talking
about representing biological data in
the Wolfram language I will start by
kind of introducing what this is all
about we're really going to be
introducing some near-term functionality
so under development we're some things
coming out in kind of undocumented or
document is experimental and 12.1 and
kind of moving into 12.2 and kind of a
broader functional picture of just kind
of where we're thinking about taking
this whole domain and then we'll
conclude so biological sequence
processing analysis for discovering
relative comparisons to all different
species different individuals different
cell types you know different
developmental stages pathological versus
you know working all of those things by
and that's enabled by representing you
know biologically similar sequences as
you know kind of linear linear sequences
of text really kind of exploiting what
makes it's possible but through that
representation so we're going to our
sharing some proposed features here well
they were still under development until
it's a collaboration feedback every time
we bring this stuff to new people
there's a lot of great suggestions a lot
of things that can happen here so really
excited to hear what any of you might
have to share so just to kind of give a
very brief you know kind of fill in some
some biology background if you've
wandered in to talk by accident so
here's some DNA it's you know two
strands together they only bind together
if the residues map and complementary
pairs
and this really allows the kind of the
maintenance and duplication of heritable
information so this is what allows you
know evolution and data to be processed
from generation to generation so but in
these parents kind of each three of
these forms a codon that's then
translated further so here we see that
the kind of we have the structure of you
know a kind of of the gene we say here
are the parts of the sequence that
regulated that tell when the gene should
be activated versus not determine which
determine what kind of cell it is and
all that good stuff then once that kind
of you're into the kind of the gene
proper here
that's transcribed into messenger RNA
that have just a little bit that allows
it to feed into the part that actually
can build the protein the ribosome and
here's the part that actually does the
protein at that which does kind of the
work of the cell so we a we can I guess
represent these sequences so we here we
have let's see here is that it's
probably pretty small for you all but I
guess so we have a DNA sequence we have
kind of all what's later is its length
and it's kind of its composition
broken-down RNA also supported amino
acids similarly we can break those down
we don't it doesn't have to be a
particular sequence oftentimes in the
lab we just know you know it's this many
terms long we don't know what it is
that's fine
degenerate sequences so the there's a
kind of a standard alphabet that says
you know what bases are allowed for
example a can only be is one chemical
and B just happens to be everything
that's not a so we support all the
standards for DNA and RNA and amino
acids well oftentimes
we'll have some some kind of other
unsupported you know thing that's just
really kind of handy to represent like
if we're adding a particular chemical to
cap off a sequence of DNA something
coming off a piece of lab equipment
particular indicator it's good just to
have something that you can kind of just
throw on there that's unspecified and if
it's a if it's a known type you can
convert it later if you didn't specify
the type at the time if you figure it
later determine what it is and you can
build these compound sequences so this
is really handy for the case but I
described before where you have some DNA
sequences coming off of equipment
they're capped with like a fluorine or
something you could just attack on there
and represent this as a mixed sequence
type here so this is integrated with our
kind of entity system kind of the these
biological sequences they represent kind
of the space that individual genes
represent kind of points within so here
we ask this gene for its reference bio
sequence of get back a bio sequence and
it's annotated with the species and the
chromosome and the orientation and
positions and all kinds of good stuff
like that similarly if you take bio
sequence and you just give it a gene or
protein it'll give you the most
appropriate by a sequence for that
entity so it's supposing you have a bio
sequence and you'd like to find some
information about it or some features
with it you can do that with find bio
sequence features here's an example
where we say here's some arbitrary
sequence we don't know what it is we
don't really have any information about
it we're gonna say where could that be
on the human genome and it says okay we
found a bio sequence position it's on
chromosome 16 at this particular
position on the plus strand from this
particular assembly of the human genome
and that corresponds to this particular
position inside of the given sequence so
even if this sequence has some mutations
or what-have-you it'll still seek
through and try and find you know a good
foot
that will that will match similarly you
can find if you have a gene that you're
looking for you can find what where that
gene corresponds to so it in your bio
sequence along this range you know that
corresponds to this segment of the of
the gene now or if you want to find kind
of just all of the human genes within
your bio sequence that you can do that
to say you're looking for maybe a
particular mutation you've read in the
so some journal that you know this
particular mutation is now associated
with a particular disease and you're
worried about that or some positive
trait you can find yeah where that
corresponds to the kind of your sequence
at hand or you can just discover all of
the mutations that that what kind of one
might have so this by by default will
return kind of the feature that's found
so it'll find the segment of of the gene
in this case and so the feature and the
position along the bio sequence that you
gave it if you'd like to extract the
sequence associated with the found
feature you can do that by just applying
this sequence command here and this
sequence is your version of the sequence
for that gene so that this is we have
some support with both molecule
chemistry developers will be exposing
this sequence molecule here eventually
and with that we can give them bio
sequences and translate them into the
underlying molecule and then all the
chemistry stuff will also apply and not
only I we also have some functionality
that applies to you know some we're
extending some of our other existing
functionality random instances of bio
sequences so get three DNA sequences of
length fifty
so one kind of neat feature is if you
have ran take random instance of these
degenerate sequences so s can either
stand for G or C so you can kind of
describe the space that you want a kind
of sample within using these degenerate
tournament terminology you can also use
weighted choices
so here's sampling from a or C and you
can also use degenerate terms in this
sampling format so this is 20% will be a
and then 80% will be everything that's
not a so six sequences each nine one
sequence alignment also works on bio
sequences thank goodness and but also it
it has some knowledge of the degenerate
basis so that Gigi can match NN and
auntie can match two so that we you
actually get can get like you know a
kind of a perfect match between
different degenerate sequences if it's
if they're supported similarity yeah n
is really kind of the wild card it's in
any any base so and that'll that'll
match similarly with sequence similarity
here we say that by allowing the similar
degenerate basis these sequences are
more similar and needleman-wunsch also
supports this improvement the longest
common sequence positions subsequence
you know this entire family also works
also matches degenerate terms so that
you can find you know
yeah matching sub sequences here and
have all that respected so now kind of
moving on to
compliments and conversions so earlier
we saw that the kind of the DNA strand
was two-sided so when you look at kind
of the other side you get the the
compliment so here a GG translated to
TCC often the biologically they're often
actually read in the river off in the
reverse order so we also provide kind of
this reverse complement here
transcribe' converts the DNA into RNA
and inverse transcribe will convert it
back translation so this is the process
by which the it's actually converted
into the protein into the sequence of
amino acids so here we see the one
translation and an inverse translation
to take it back
inverse translation can actually many
different codons all correspond to a
particular amino acid so this is this
one is just by default you get a sample
but if you supply all you can get all
combinations thereof there's a bio
sequence inverse translation count so
you know how many of them you're getting
actually one it's going to go off script
here so that blows up really fast so
that's a good thing to have translate we
support I guess entities for all of the
common sequence translation tables
supported by standards so if you have
mitochondrial DNA or some weird RKL DNA
or so forth you can have a translation
that works for you oftentimes you're
going to end up in the situation where
you're not kind of perfectly aligned
where you have this kind of frameshift
sort of phenomenon so because every
three letters is what's translated if
you get off by one that's a big problem
and it really kind of messes with sort
of your analysis there so
we offer the ability to just you know
jump to a start codon so that you end up
with kind of the that kind of the
translation that's appropriate or if
you'd like to manually adjust it then
that's provided to move either forward
or backward on the frame either dropping
terms or adding degenerate terms as
necessary so we uh that's all kind of a
lot to keep track of and if you just
like to just convert it for me and I
don't care about the details then by a
sequence convert is your friend you just
go ahead and give it the type and it
will convert it to whichever one is most
appropriate again all here will give you
all the cases and there's a bio sequence
conversion count so it doesn't blow up
in your face so I guess we also
supplying some functionality for
matching and validating bio sequences so
is it is this actually a legitimate bio
sequence or term is fully specified is
it DNA is it fully specified DNA all of
that and we also have some a bio
sequence match queue to handle kind of
matching these degenerate terms so some
more degenerate term resolution here if
you have something where you have a
degenerate term and you'd like a sample
that's some fully nice fully resolved
sequence well that's going to be
provided again sit the same convention
give it all you get back all the
combinations yes and no so it's it's
it's Garen to be the same each time but
it is arbitrary so if you you know if
you run it again and again you'll get
back the same there's gonna be no
surprises in terms of like you know it's
not a it's not a random instance but you
know
just yeah so it kind of gives you our
choice there and and same story by a
sequence to generate as much count Oh
avoid the combinatorial explosion so
that's some of the functionality we're
gonna be releasing in the near term I
guess we have we're really looking at
quite a lot of different functional
areas to extend this to I've highlighted
some here that I'll be looking at in the
next few slides but certainly if you see
anything of here that's interest please
please let me know so I get one common
problem is that you'll be interested in
having built in support for a type that
we haven't provided such as if you have
some like RKL transfer RNA or if you
have hedge emoji DNA or you have some
you know you know new synthetic alphabet
that you'd like support it as though
it's first class yeah I think we're
really interested in in that in using
kind of the entity store mechanism to
allow users to provide their own types
that can then convert between our types
such as for example making some organism
specific wobble compliments between our
RNA and some ribosome specific tRNA
definitions we're also really kind of
interested in some data indexing and
providing search and feature annotation
capabilities I mean right now we have
some genome look up some snip finding
that you've seen and we would
potentially do protein lookup and others
as as there's demand for them you know
one thing that seems to be you know a
relatively short follow-on extension
from this is kind of doing the 23andme
thing labeling these snips by what kind
of what features they correspond to what
diseases they correspond to heritage and
evolutionary markers to
so give me all of the snips in this gene
that correspond to some set of traits or
some set of diseases could be very
interesting a lot of times we're going
to be in the situation where users are
looking into their their researchers
they're really looking into their
particular species or they're really
looking into something that's
proprietary and so be able to use things
like find bio sequence features for
their or can afford their data is kind
of taking the index stuff that we have
built internally and being able to
expose it is a Ventris and also there's
a lot there are so many great
bioinformatics resources out there to be
able to then you know have provide an
API not worry about building a separate
index to use something that you've
already built is going to be key for us
I think so we're also looking at
improvements to alignments and
structural comparisons the many-to-many
feature to sequence alignment is very
popular doing RNA sequencing kind of
taking a tabulate bio sequence features
where we have kind of many different
sequences coming in and then and then
kind of putting them together it's
closely related to sequence assembly
both where you have some reference that
you're going against and you're building
kind of the assembly on the fly without
reference we're looking into expending
our sequence alignment from pairwise
multiple alignment kind of some
many-to-many alignment comparisons that
go with kind of the RNA seek school
before the really differential
expression seeing when you know normal
versus diseased situation really being
able to display and compare those and
determine if those are statistically
significant for a given pathway with
enrichment analysis
so I guess the other big problem or
challenge that kind of we're facing is
that the biological sequence processing
there are so many scripts and tools out
there that are really kind of
distributed and it's kind of there's
it's deployed in pretty much every
single possible way a containerized
deployment is becoming progressively
more popular and we really think that
kind of wolf WolframAlpha wolfram
notebooks and you know the kind of the
Wolfram engine is really kind of fits
really well into this both is kind of
like a prototyping platform for then
deploying containerized scripts and then
also as an environment for receiving the
results of containerized workflow so in
conclusion we're really threatened to
fill how how Wolfram language can
support biological sequence processing
and there's many directions as you've
seen in which this work will develop and
so your suggestions can still be
incorporated into our designs thank you
[Applause]